hi and welcome back to sarahs music my
guest today is a musician on a mission a
mandolin mission grammy-nominated Abby
Abby tile is just the best ambassador
for his instrument and I'm really
looking forward to spending the day
today here in Berlin with him and his
mandolin
as you could see Abby has to walk around
a lot carrying his mandolin for the
cameras but today I thought we travelled
in style so tell me I said that you're a
musician on a mandolin mission your
mission is to bring the mandolin into
concert halls yes I think I think there
was a gap in the history of music were
like for 200 years the mandolin was sort
of ignored by this by the sears
composers by the major concert hall and
wasn't because the mandolin wasn't
popular it was very popular instrument
throughout the time but as an amateur
instrument not as a concert hall
instrument and indeed think that it has
a lot to offer in today's concert hall
and and therefore to kind of bring it
back
to be honest I really didn't know much
about the mandolin at all it's a sort of
instrument that um you sort of know
about but there are so many stringed
instruments um that I wasn't quite you
know you have to sort of really be sure
it you've turned it into this sort of
cult instrument people you sell out
concert hall how have you done that no I
well I think it has to do with the we've
all heard and so so much we are exposed
to so many different kinds of music and
different artists throughout to social
meetings on and I think we're at the
point where a lot of the great classical
music has been recorded has been
performed and people are hungry to
something new when I go on stage
recently I have this thought in my head
that for eighteen ninety percent of the
people sitting in that concert hall is
the very first time they hear a sound of
a mandolin life and it excites me I know
that this is completely fresh to them
and I'm about to expose them to
something they didn't know before and
this is this is actually a lot of fun
you study with a violin teacher because
my own injury it's tuned the same as a
violin it is so it's perfect to play all
the repertoire yeah it's true I mean
that my first each teacher was a
violinist because there wasn't a
mandolin teacher and you know you just
happened to be there a teacher and my
first teacher was a trombone player yeah
what were the horn or doing with the
room you see ya there weren't any one
player this is the way to go yeah
obviously you live in Berlin why did you
choose Berlin I mean it's obviously a
fantastic Madrid Open it's a perfect
moment to ask why did you choose
Berlin's on it but it's true I felt that
I mean when I when I still living in
Italy and and coming to Berlin for
performances and touring passing through
Berlin I started to realize that was
let's say my first time in Berlin was
about 10 years ago I start to realize
her something really special happening
in the city
it's going to amazing phase that we
don't know it's going to repeat and how
long it will last and I just want it to
be part of the party so I think it's
about time for a serenade what do you
think have you ever played your mandolin
in a rickshaw befo so how about it we go
I'll put this down here okay what should
we have today something fitting your
weather so a V I've never been to a
plucked instruments picnic in the park
before this is fantastic so what do we
have here we have the bouzouki from
Greece yes this is the bouzouki I just
brought some of the instruments that I
have at home but obviously I have a lot
of them so this is bad
this is a band ariya this this is where
Spanish version of a black string
instruments still used for fall spanish
music not very tuned this is a venetian
mandolin it is a it is the instrument
that we've already called a mandala that
was the black string instrument in the
peroxide is this on your CD yes I did
yeah this is the napolitan mandolin
social barackman this is how the
mandolin look like in Naples software of
the 18th century and that's actually the
instrumented survived so for double
strings of metal it's not what this is
how it ends up in modern time but but
yes this is the one you you perform on
regularly you can see this this can you
see that you can see this is all it's
all really you yeah that's where you
slide that's not at all is not as all it
is as it looks like it's a modern it's
not as it is a motion it was built in
israel by by this amazing guy Herman
who's this crustacean genius and he
decided to design a mandolin that would
fit a modern concept like to show this
to you guys look this is Ali's Pickers
plectrum and you have them all over your
although in all your trouser pockets do
they get your washing machines in there
all in the washer sometimes get them
look old listed on a super 8 sometimes
one in a salad one day you found one in
a salad yummm anyway so but you need you
you don't you don't use your finger you
always use the pub the plaque gym with
the period so that the basic technique
is that you blocked you feed the string
will it be
yeah and that what makes this sound if I
put it with a finger would can happen so
the sound is quite immediate it's the
encounter of a hard plastic with a very
tense metal so it's very clear causes
these colors in your sound if you're
using a holla with the platform because
there are different way i can i can i
can pluck on the metal if i did
completely parallel it sounds like these
but first off this sound i would just
play with the angle there are some
people that have made the Madeline quite
apart from yourself made the mandolin
quite cool right what about it let's
save my childhood I was like whenever
pits kids at school said all the
mandolin is not cool i had losing my
religion to us what is it
so Abby we've had a great day I've
learned so much about the mandolin
already and now we're at the Berlin
arena where there's an electronic music
festival going on there is so I mean
look at this I don't know really know
quite younger than the average as i get
to see play and all the cops at houses
all around the world what why is it
important to you to play in the gig like
this oh this is wonderful i think it
brings together audience that not not
necessarily use to hear classical music
in the space worried it feels
comfortable places they would normally
go to party or to listen to music and
now then being offer their different
music you think they wouldn't feel
comfortable in a comfortable I think
they woods but exactly but this is the
first the first step probably told you
all right
Oh
you
Wow
anyhow people don t two is about a
fantastic hope you enjoyed it to you
next time I like there's no getting away
from it off to take the horn challenge
in put your hand in like that's fine
professional